the British people voted for change they
voted to shape a brighter future for our
country they voted to leave the European
Union and embrace the world and they did
so with their eyes open accepting that
the road ahead will be uncertain at
times but believing that it leads
towards a brighter future for their
children and their grandchildren - and
it is the job of this government to
deliver it that means more than
negotiating our new relationship with
the EU it means taking the opportunity
of this great moment of national change
to step back and ask ourselves what kind
of country we want to be my answer is
clear
I want this United Kingdom to emerge
from this period of change stronger
fairer more United and more outward
looking than ever before I want us to be
a secure prosperous tolerant country a
magnet for international talent and a
home to the pioneers and innovators who
will shape the world ahead I want us to
be a truly global Britain the best
friend and neighbour to our European
partners but a country that reaches
beyond the borders of Europe to a
country that goes out into the world to
build relationships with old friends and
new allies alike I want Britain to be
what we have the potential talent and
ambition to be a great global trading
nation that is respected around the
world and strong confident and United at
home that is why this government has a
plan for Britain one that gets us the
right deal abroad but also ensures we
get a better deal for ordinary working
people at home it's why that plan sets
out how we will use this moment of
change to build a stronger economy and a
fairer society by embracing Jenny
economic and social reform why our new
modern industrial strategy is being
developed to ensure every nation and
area of the United Kingdom can make the
most of the opportunities ahead why we
will go further to reform our schools to
ensure every child has the knowledge and
the skills they need to thrive in post
brexit Britain why as we continue to
bring the deficit down we will take a
balanced approach by investing in our
economic infrastructure because it can
transform the gross potential of our
economy and improve the quality of
people's lives across the whole country
it's why we will put the preservation of
our precious union at the heart of
everything we do because it is only by
coming together as one great union of
Nations and people that we could make
the most of the opportunities ahead the
result of the referendum was not a
decision to turn inward and retreat from
the world because Britain's history and
culture is profoundly internationalist
we are a European country and proud of
our shared European heritage but we are
also a country that has always looked
beyond Europe to the wider world that is
why we are one of the most racially
diverse countries in Europe one of the
most multicultural members of the
European Union and why whether we're
talking about India Pakistan Bangladesh
America Australia Canada New Zealand
countries in Africa all those that are
closer to home in Europe so many of us
have close friends and relatives from
across the world instinctively we want
to travel to study in trade with
countries not just in Europe but beyond
the borders of our continent even now as
we prepare to leave the EU we are
planning for the next biennial
Commonwealth Heads of Government Meeting
in 2018 a reminder of our unique and
proud global relationships and it is
important to recognize this fact June
the 23rd
was not the moment Britain chose to step
back from the world it was the moment we
chose to build a truly global Britain I
know that this and the other reasons
Britain took such a decision it's not
always well understood among our friends
and allies in Europe and I know many
fear that this might herald the
beginning of a greater unraveling of the
EU but let me be clear I do not want
that to happen it would not be in the
best interests of Britain
it remains overwhelmingly and
compellingly in Britain's national
interest that the EU should succeed and
that is why I hope in the months and
years ahead we will all reflect on the
lessons of Britain's decision to leave